[Music]
it's time to wash this off
there's so much glitter I can't
even begin to process how we're going to
get this off and this is like powder
that you put in slime oh I'll just try
and get this up
can you Carol just be glitter in my hair
for the rest of my life after this and
you know what I'm kind of okay for that
actually put some of this jbn pre-washed
stuff oil in my hair let's go in with
our first round of Champions
keep going in with shampoo until I feel
like it's good
you know what it actually came out
better than I expected I don't know if
there's glitter in it still but it's
pretty good and all like a little Sun
powder stuff is out so I would call that
a success
[Music]